[Music]
[Music]
hello and in typical game saw fashion
you know we have we had a little bit of
technical issues but I'm here with ma
Jamaa ohayo-gozaimasu hi we are arte and
I sorry I can only see out of one eye so
I'm like kind of distracted yeah the
game is actually starting right now
we're playing we're playing we're
playing Delta rune but the thing is
before if you're watching and you care
about undertale I will say obviously
there will be spoilers spoilers and
you're definitely gonna want to play for
yourself
so please and Toby Fox is also issued
like kind of like a request that you
don't talk about it for 24 hours and we
are defying it in some sort of way by
playing it here on a stream but outside
of the stream I will not talk about it
for 24 hours
so please if you care about undertale
come back in 24 hours that's cool so you
can't fullscreen the game also another
thing to worry about if you guys are if
you guys didn't know this already is
supposedly there's like some kind of
deleting yeah there's a I think Toby Fox
has said that whatever is in the
whatever the uninstaller dot exe
whatever directory that's in it will
delete the files that are in that but
it's not I don't think it's gonna like
delete stuff off our computers at least
I hope it won't but we'll we'll cross
that bridge when we get there
also for the person that said like
undertale system isn't an undertale
successor that could be true i put the
question mark out there just because
it's made by the same guy yeah this
could be a prequel it could be a hint to
a sequel but there's some relatable
things to it yes yeah so before we get
into this it is it's incomplete he's
Toby Fox has said but a home boy Jordan
romaine has been playing this for about
an hour and says he still hasn't seen
the end
yeah so there's gonna be a lot to this
it's an it I guess it's sort of an
incomplete game but there's still a lot
going on here and again please I
understand there's a spoiler warning and
Toby Fox has requested that people don't
talk about for another 24 hours so if
you don't want to hear anything about
this or see anything about it
get out now but if you're down let's do
it remove the mask dude why alright
alright the mass is gone alright so if
you if anyone or did you want me to
remove me straight up I'll leave
we don't want person scream yeah before
okay well he's trying to preface that
you know hey if you are worried about
spoilers I care about you know that's
why I remove the mask these guys got the
legs like the hero that you prefer who
would you like to be on this Halloween
day makes sense this kinda looks like
Yukari talked about all right do it is
that the one you want to do yeah I'm
using a controller buddy okay
Oh was it not taking the input I like
how they asked you to pick a torso but
I'm pretty sure they're like the same no
the hands are cool I guess or a little
bit wider
you got a different outfit this is like
a just got some buttons I'll go with
this one okay you can get the game in
full-screen Oh
have you tried f11 but it's gonna be in
four by three now and then if we if we
fullscreen it yeah it might be four by
three but I didn't do anything
alright and the the maximize thing is
blocked out so I think I'm in the
settings or something okay but how are
you guys
we're doing good it's a Halloween day we
got a bunch of people in the office are
actually dressed up I am NOT the closest
thing I had was a Jew baka mask which
Reena sin really didn't like so I got
rid of it there's a couple of mask
options I couldn't win with though today
do you accept it yes this is gonna be me
alright yeah undertale means a lot to me
so this is it's kind of weird having to
stream it rather than experiencing it
for myself but Dad this is Horst your
hand Erte is an influential individual
I'm trying alt-enter
boom thank you let me fix it I'll mix
I'll fix this while you you play how
about that what is my favorite type of
food painting Wow I like salty salty
like you Eric
I saw your favorite blood type I'll just
go what's this ain't no blood type maybe
the thing about undertale is that it's
always been creepy
it's add some horrifying elements to it
if you did the true lab in undertale
then you would know what's up with that
what color does it I feel like no do we
really gain that much space I feel like
we did and we didn't you know what I
mean oh by moving it I know by like alt
entering it it's fine I'll still also
adjust where don't worry please give it
a gift what I know work up to the right
this feels like very this feels weighty
what is even going on you I'm sorry I'm
playing my own game right now I'm
playing the game we're trying to crop
this buddy feel this thing so we can get
this 4 by 3 to be play a little nicer
how do you feel about your creation
although the text isn't being cut off
which is mostly have you taught answered
honestly yes oh there it goes Jesus
Christ what's up you acknowledge the
possibility of payment seizure yes
name your vessel
I named her Frannie in undertale because
that's the name of one of my homeboys
his name is Franz off is this fine with
you yeah that's good
alright I could even go half camera face
of each of us I'll get fancy let's get
fancy all right I'm gonna play my own
game over here sure thank you guys all
for tuning in of course odd I got telcos
I mas C name I'll name her name or
Yukari because she looks like Yukari
talking about from persona 3 Yukari
where's the K I can't spell I don't know
the alphabet every time I got a you got
one eye right now though yeah yeah if
anything gets messed up it's cuz I got
one eye I respect that
you gotta have respect I'm such a bleep
that's alright
ain't nothing wrong with being a weeb
what the creator we wear proudly here
dude my own name oh geez
let's go modulo Chima it makes me think
of hajima that's Korean Wow
that's me ma Jima on the grater
oh just funny like the hell I like
characters from like other games so you
should be on the top hey that's me happy
Halloween everyone
happy Halloween hope everyone's doing
well hope you get all the candy and all
that stuff that you want tonight all
right
boom it'll work
yeah yeah we fancy now look we all right
you know what I could have put us on the
left it's Chris that's what that's me
toriel is back oh geez I do think this
is a prequel I haven't read anything
about this leading up to this is that
like blood in the corner I need the bed
oh no it's probably just too messed up
forward our pin say stain stain alright
so a lot of undertale if you haven't
played is a inspecting environment and
getting like text boxes about it so
we're gonna be doing a lot of that so it
might be uneventful for you if you're
looking for action it's fine what a
melon says I already played it today and
then you gameplay is so amazing okay
that's good right I hope that a lot of
people in the chatter people who care
about undertale and have already played
it so let's go
I haven't played it oh not that you care
wow if you cared about you would have
already
oh there's ska cool we've got some Scott
tunes in here I hope to hear some and
another thing too this one a year your
big games that year right 2015 was yeah
this is like a game of like a generation
for me it's a beautiful it's a beautiful
day outside if y'all know kind of like a
little bit is this guy a pirate for
Halloween boy you don't even know ma
Jima if he could right now go through
this internet and get to the other side
he'd slap you upside the head
/ you upside the head actually the
people will find out who you are this
coming month because it's gonna be a
PlayStation Plus free oh yeah so you
know
Majin was everywhere in that game yeah
you go you bout to find out okay
redo lane says this is like a demo
though yeah it's kind of like a someone
was also like throughout the word like
maybe a proof of concept or something
like you know as Michael said it's not a
complete game yeah but you know it's got
some it's quite substantial all things
considered
mmm-hmm it's only you this is very yeah
this is exactly like kind of a this is
directly related to undertale okay
anyone don't know this is directly
related to undertale for those people
saying that my thumbnail was incorrect
its I don't know if it's a successor and
if you all played a earthbound this also
should look familiar right here I also
did leave myself out by putting the
question mark there yeah that's what I
like thing you want to slap me my guy
geez I don't know I'm just saying like
that's what his persona like yeah I know
right like that's that's what Maggio
would do I'm not saying that like we
would know it modulo would like probably
take a knife or a bat I know probably
knock you out the bat that's called
Delta rune that's correct is it already
on Steam no but you can't download it
for free just be careful about the
potential uninstalls as we had mentioned
or like it deletes files which is kind
of scary but jeez there's a lot of
inspecting the environment because you
want flood hit yes yeah nasty
Oh same sound from undertale sick you
flushed it
do you know was there anything in there
no you just do it alright catch shampoo
cool yeah this is this is a lot a big
chunk of undertale it's fine there's
boss fights and stuff to you I know that
yeah let's see if I can call my god yeah
yeah why who has a landline anymore
let's be real feels like so archaic like
I like my desk phone but my desk phone
only exists for security don't you
anyone guess that's good calls it your
adust phone not really I don't get too
many personally but like they're
definitely awesome wow this is this is
great this is crazy is your mind blown
right now
damn I like this epic music like shits
about to happen
[Music]
that is your boy map had to just call
you captain Captain Jack Sparrow that's
what I'm saying
Cara so this is coming to PlayStation
question no Savi
I meant that mod like if you didn't know
who madhyama was I was saying that
PlayStation Plus free games remember
mommy is jock is a kiwami and I think
Bulletstorm so someone started Polk's
thinks that this might be a sequel or
must be a sequel as what they say it's
the music that's playing is a same same
tune as one of the songs in undertale
also so this is directly ties we don't
know exactly how you said that it could
be a prequel you know could you know oh
my god I think this is man this could be
a prequel this could be a sequel on
based on the best ending this is alphys
offices in undertale a major character
in on the tail
who's your partner oh let's see um
oh god this person I hate this person
from undertale um I'll be friends with
you Wow switch or at least please maybe
down the road rs life cuz didn't
undertale undertale game on switch
earlier this year which i said something
for the review yes you did
[Music]
who is Chris someone asks Chris is the
main character I guess you'll find out
who Chris is maybe Krista was the you
know you looked more like an alligator
there for some reason
that's neg yeah but whatever undertale
the name that is melted be cryptic then
this is the snowed in town it's a remix
of the snowed in town song oh damn
dang are you gonna be forced to choose
one person you wanna make a group of
three yeah sure miss alphys gonna be
like mad
alphys is a pushover well not there
abort oh geez okay I guess not
they shouldn't be making groups of three
though there's only nine students yo the
ho [ __ ] forever alone Oh yo rebel Oh who
dis Suzie five u5i double Detroit smash
sure well I know one of my hero
references reading chat bro
gadget-gadget student yeah he is he's
taco Yami
Takayama Tokoyo me yeah the bird guy I
was like where's this dark shadow though
United States a smash go beyond plus all
show oh we will let's play my heroin
[ __ ] once justice no it's not for
undertale is based on like very heavily
based on dialogue reading dialogue text
so it's kind of hard to it's it's a
tough game to stream
alright what a melon does the story play
before or after we don't know yeah we
don't know yet we don't know we're fine
we gotta find out our board Jordan
outside was playing before we got on
stream and he was at least like you said
roughly an hour in yeah wasn't done yet
so we'll get at least an hour and maybe
we won't go the whole way yeah we'll see
you I'll leave that up to Michael just
because you've played it so yeah you
know you have a better gauge and like
what's overly spoilery as we mentioned
earlier too though if you want to see
this for the first time for yourself you
should probably stop watching the stream
we're just gonna go through it because
it's a new game you know obviously drop
this morning for those that enjoy the
game like you might not be able to get
to play it yet and wanted to see it so
cool thanks for hanging out if you don't
go I understand and hopefully if you
have played this all the way through
please keep the chat spoiler free or
just talk about the only things that
we've covered so far all right well
maybe we won't get to the ending Yotam
but they said they'd finish the game and
they made me fall
where do you download this believe they
tweeted Delta rune okay someone says
it's not a prequel okay
oh that's kind of us again why I don't
know I don't know if that person they
could be giving me the trolls you know
someone else says alternate universe
maybe yeah maybe someone else saying
sequel maybe well find out we never know
is it on Steam no it's not steam sauna
steam it's a direct download oh look at
this was that like a have a bird yeah
it's it's an enemy and like this uh one
of the enemies in the early early game
wonder tell Susie leave she's like now
incoming class yeah
you soon as you lose let's help this we
got nobody to partner with alphys you
want to partner with us get out there
all right oh are you social partner with
Susie yeah or maybe a word in detention
I sorry I it's hard to read and dream at
the same time what you eating there I
was it's gonna be a battle ten squabble
okay what was that follow Susie all
right we got it we got it reduce no
worries and people be upset when you
don't do it right away I know I don't
know we've got to get bullied or she
can't kiss us can't tell we're friends
[Applause]
[Music]
you're gonna be quiet
ill sheets on the chalk
she loves cha sama snitch
[Music]
dang oh damn was a savage bro real
carnage down yeah we got some yellow ass
teeth oh [ __ ]
Oh foaming at the mouth oh she's gonna
eat us Oh JK JK huh it's just weird and
I start start
happy Halloween I guess trick-or-treat
it's a trick dang oh my god what whoa
whoa I didn't have an answer
oh you didn't know just okay I'm getting
like real creeped out your choices don't
matter
that's not true do you think if you did
a hella fast you could have stopped it I
don't know like one of those like you
had like a one-second opportunity no you
can get it free Delta ruin calm y'all
undertale does a lot of it for yourself
if you want to check it out obviously as
I mentioned if you played on your tail
you're gonna have a little bit more
stake in it but you might have a stake
in it too if you just want to explore
and try something new like stick yeah
stick is good I love a stake right now
hell yeah someone gets steak for lunch
damn that's cold
whoa watch yes I just want to get a
drink of water down
[Music]
that's a pretty good reference to
undertale there's a lot of references
and stuff in here so it's picking up on
most of it if there's something I missed
then I need to replay it but cool boy
can anyone tell me what the heck is
going on you know try to go to school
was supposed to partner yeah duck
partner with a bully that like watching
chalk some stranger things type [ __ ]
[Music]
let's try to keep spoilers to a minimum
in chat yeah in chat please if you've
already played this great I'm glad
you're tuning in yeah they put up a
reference but still oh just a just in
case okay but yeah I'm just trying to
throw it out there now although me
throwing it out there I feel like it's
just gonna trigger people man I like our
facial animation those bubble text
changes yeah but that's another thing
that undertale does extremely well is
like conveying emotion with like pixel
art it's a real accomplishment I think
little piece of candy piece candy can't
find a switch should either come on need
a Nintendo switch perhaps are we going
come on he's said on the website not to
say anything about 24 hours man hey we
for warned a long time ago about
spoilers yeah I mean I mean if you
deliberately there we stop the autoplay
on the site so no one would come across
the site to see it auto-playing
so if you deliberately like the only way
to join the streams that deliberately
like click on it and get into it so so I
mean you brought yourself here so you
can either watch it or you don't have to
so they're hanging out awesome cool if
you want to get out that's fine too yeah
like I I feel like I'm tired of like
people being upset about spoilers when
they click into it themselves like it's
like dude you brought yourself there
it's very evident what we are doing so
yeah hopefully I told - they put some
spoiler warning in the text so no one
accidentally stumbles upon it and we've
said it at least multiple times now if
you're worried about spoilers and you
want to try it for yourself you should
definitely get out of here yeah I want
to hang out and just come along in the
ride with us great I'm not gonna be like
talking about it on Twitter we're not
gonna be talking about it on the site
outside of the stream I think the only
thing we won't mention is like it's
available be careful about it
potentially like deleting a files and
then you know hey if you want to watch
it and you don't want to play it
yourself go ahead here you go here you
go but if if not yeah that's fine hoo
boy so apparently we fell oh great this
is oh this is really creepy this is
basically the start of undertale nice
same thing wait a second I think I know
nevermind I was thinking of a connection
a theory a theory however you will keep
that theory to yourself I said yeah oh
why my name ma gee MA no way what they
said to me
I was like dude don't tell me it like
it's in a like read like hey Raja does a
face can recognize yeah oh by the way
sure to put spoiler tag on the preview
image maybe sure I mean like there's
only so many things you can do to like
here I'll put it in the title to to help
facilitate things that's why I'm just
saying like there's only so many things
you can do to like try to tell people
like in a way I do feel like it's
implied that if we're streaming this
game by nature of what undertale is you
would know that it's a spoiler warning
but yeah a sketch to put like texts in
the title to make sure that people
understand that this is going to be
spoilery by nature of streaming the game
but i won't be talking about outside the
stream so yeah
I will now even put it in the
description even though nobody reads
titles and descriptions I swear to God I
should you not like some people will
come in and say what are we playing and
it's like in the title I don't know what
to do
Michael a man I cannot protect everybody
this is creeping me out dude it this is
released today on Halloween so I imagine
there are gonna be horror elements to it
Jesus Christ gift but he's on a
controller that might be oh okay this is
oh cool we got revamped menu have any
items I said that would our body
contains a human soul ooh Besant
undertale reference right there config
controls see okay gamepad
okay
oops sorry good there yeah oh oh this is
some real-time battles now we're not
sure super mandible claw oh geez okay
we're doing real-time fights now no
longer turn-based
what is this destiny we got the light
why are the light light levels I puzzle
was geez only have one of them there I
coulda sworn there was like a an
alternate path who you speedrunning now
it's spam you a speedrunner yeah the
look so that doesn't have done here I
want to see what's here mr. Adrian see
says perfect Halloween gift yeah seems
like yeah let's look along inside take
it yes you got the touch glow chard I
thought you were gonna get some type of
power or I thought like I thought maybe
those things we're gonna start shooting
me because he took it
show me shard its uses unknown you maybe
this is I don't know never mind I'm not
the same thing there's an auto run
setting in the options as well okay
alright seems like you know what you're
doing now so
only I was blinded by darkness but don't
you have the light right now well I'm
wearing on my okay this is like a puzzle
okay am I supposed to get them all open
well each one I would assume so like the
two dark is probably like like that so
like I don't know is that what it's
supposed to be or is it all try that one
being like dark only the far-right one
cuz that that's because you see how
there's patterns underneath I don't know
if that does anything well the the
pattern underneath tells you what it
does Oh gotcha okay yeah so maybe I need
a make them all dark now you're gonna
try to jump it Oh No
yeah he did say it did say like only the
eyes with the darkness could see in this
there we go right nice damn you stood
with one eye how'd you get this game
Delta ruin calm just be mindful that it
has the potential to delete files so if
you're curious are worried about that go
to games.com
just to get clarification on how that
all works are do you know how that all
works I've heard that the uninstall Exe
whatever's in that in that folder with
that file will delete everything in that
folder so it doesn't seem like that
it'll be that big of a deal
oh okay yeah so it's not as it sounds
worse than it is
right whoa oh you ain't hiding no more
we're taking these little side things
away
oh Jesus is this this is my homie it
looks like Susy though yeah oh that's
very saying yeah well they got that
different gear on yeah cuz I look like
I'm undead I look like a zombie
o'clock in the face since when
who made you leader family people
already started working on fan art
that's tight
yeah we're not get Joe ass out of here
the hell you tomba you got us into this
mess yes right follow me what a bully
does though yeah let me get a race fine
we should go the other way we should go
the other way like just kidding oh geez
whoa whoa is that one eye patch it's
only got one eye right now it's hard
it's also really weird how how much
light goes into one eye when you block
out one the other two eyes bro not do
like oh you gotta stay in character also
I can't speak Japanese so I can't really
stay in character home told Escott what
does that mean it's an onion oh geez
Oh it'll be a boss battle Austin Jackson
saying this if for anyone interested
this game is an episodic game this is
the first episode is free and on the
website right now I didn't know that
that's cool if that's true that's
actually pretty dope look at this look
at a speedrun in I'll give you some
we're pump that out here I'll pump them
how did you not get hit by what wait
what's going on and once you see that oh
okay I don't get it like directly
yeah directly I was about to say there's
that one that like flew like right by
your face but that's how good you are at
dodging my bad I guess we need to test
it for science oh oh okay yeah I like
how this is like an evolution of the
original undertale battle system
it's hard to tell what's coming from the
left side
I'm just saying oh that's alright not at
least everyone can see you very clearly
so they know that you only got one eye
right now he has to lie eyes in real
life but yeah I know but today is not
real life you know today is Halloween
watching wanna plays games today that's
correct
would you call it ma Jima place yeah
let's do that
Delta ruin this place seems like the
waterfall area in on the tail I feel
like this is this this might be like the
story of like undying or something
[Music]
salt Lots
I like poking and prodding and stuff but
I don't know how much I can get away
with on stream
[Music]
this looks I the art style is something
I like how it's like deformed even
though it's all pixel art to me it still
has like a 3d effects or feeling yeah
redo lane saying I think that Toby's
planning to release a new chapter every
few months it's not confirmed it's just
their thought makes sense that's free
whatever whatever Toby Fox is up to
I trust us please keep it civil and the
chat cuz you know it's just how do
people you know just get out of here
with some of that negativity we're
trying to keep the chat positive it's or
you know at least neutral and positive I
don't think every comment has to be like
a positive thing but there's definitely
no need to be aggressively negative or
just talking about stuff that is this
all for one we're not even doing in the
game and stuff like that and the prince
of this kingdom kingdom of darkness
kingdom of dankness that's how you read
it with one also so let's keep spoilers
to a minimum so I'm a timeout
I'm gonna start timing out people that
are spoiling okay yeah and it would be
best for you to do it because you don't
know or you're don't particularly care
about spoilers I would say oh I I don't
I don't care about spoils here but like
I'm gonna get rid of people that even if
you fake it I am gonna get rid of you
yeah even that like that's not cool
that's what I have decided to become
more vigilant in chat for those who are
actually
here to have fun and hang out you know
[Music]
it's a legend of guilty room okay
[Music]
Wow
[Music]
where I get Erik antivirus I can't
ah
[Music]
[ __ ] that lodging what gameplay possibly
you need to take off your shirt though
hmm can't do that in the workplace doubt
for that you could feign that it's
Halloween and this is you are in
character will character I also wanted
to bring a knife but that wouldn't work
either three heroes a human classic RPG
introduction the prince this is dope no
the music is so damn good
oh hey guys see all the fountains
[Music]
okay oh he did alpha pieces and this is
spoiler but you can get different
endings okay I mean yeah I'm a pacifist
or not I don't I don't view that as a
spoiler that's kind of like expected
given that's expected given the
undertale lineage you guys aren't
supposed to record this until 24 hours
again
we-we've I don't know how else to say
this but maybe that's someone who's just
like tuned in yeah
but yes obviously there will be spoilers
if you don't want to see him you can
leave cook-out yeah
but if you want hang out cool we've done
everything we can to try to help people
understand that there's gonna be
spoilers yeah we've now added them to
the title I'll try to add it to the
image after we've turned off autoplay in
a lot of places yes
- I deliberately asked for people to
turn off autoplay on our sites and all
our platforms so and I won't be talking
about on Twitter or anything because
that's how you run into those problems
sure when it's like unwarranted
unsolicited spoilers so that's fine when
we think they'd at least respect ya
their respect sure yeah and they're out
that's fine that's understandable
mmm those were heroes cuz like the other
way I view it too is like outside of all
the precautions we've taken there's so
many other people that are gonna do this
yeah there are there's this people like
already screamed and said like oh it
took me this long and I stopped yeah it
like I don't know I just get personally
pressured I guess as you are targeting
the stream I shouldn't you know I'll
take responsibility for that but like I
just feel like at some point what what
differentiates us in that regard from
being allowed to do that
yeah I feel ya plus I ain't gonna be
here tomorrow so I need
tell them to come after Erte it was me
your boy hashtag queynte is this is sick
I like this is this sans
now Janice
and money oh now you're in character
yeah so that's the name sauce also
who is this music okay videos I'm trying
to you know channel my inner Red Dead
even though I'm not playing come on
you've been trashing the game all day
game I jokingly trashed the game because
everyone loves it even though I know
that it's there's a lot going on in that
game a lot of cool stuff dude like
seeing Mike's walk up to a road and a
horse burning up melting and our weird
weird a sky separate I think I said that
right yo AB what is L to ruin calm go
download it if you want to play it as we
mentioned multiple times out if you're
worried about spoilers get out of here
go play the game yourself this is sick
you want to hang out the new chat with
MA Jima and some random guy named Eric
then stay and hang out that's cool this
is the new the new battle system here
oh yeah it's sick music - oh you want
some more
are you kind are you sure what the hell
you just doing damage why is it okay
okay cool this is a can I tell like
Suzie not to hurt these people
you got to be able to someone said that
you could go full pass it yeah
Komachi my lock Eric in a room with our
dr - sure but i find a way to play
something else haha
is it out yes Robbie you can play good
go check it out Delta ruin calm go
download it for free
go play get out of here go do your thing
Susie what are you doing oh [ __ ] that is
some next-level stuff there it's hurt it
hurts Susie but not me watch out
yeah good you know me and Michael we're
probably get some lunch that's what
we're gonna be doing
use warning to stop Suzi okay thank you
Yotam that's uh there's also like in
undertale things I wish I knew before I
started so things like that are super
helpful okay so it's someone said dem
gie weird MJ says you can't stop Suzi
you can only affect how enemy back with
your axe awesome okay cool
good
oh man ran yeah I ran this is like the
music and like the evolution of the
combat system so like where it's now
like an evolution of the undertale
combat system is feels really cool I
don't know that's I'm overcome with the
emotion is a good tell from looking like
yeah you have one I could tell from the
look in my eye man I wish this game was
complete so I can give it a 10 out of 10
this guy Maji mah is a rebel
he's a road a man Wow okay I get it
[Music]
what the hell
dipping outside the place sweet have fun
is he crazy Dipple that's a free demo
chapter / chapter it's pretty long yep
yeah we've heard that as well I can't
tell what that is is it like it's like
Tommy
I guess so maybe Tokyo meas a sparrow
yeah really of course or a raven or
something I think we're all sure he's
not a vulture Tommy's a good character
though all right let's see what animal
took cool yet companions
oh man music I can't I can't overstate
how much I love Toby foxes
composition and soundtracks I don't know
I I don't got an answer to toka yeah if
anyone in the chat knows what animal
Tokyo mia is from my hero let us know
yes
yeah Delta rune is this right here
that's the delta room
[Music]
yeah it's a so Rahl say is an anagram
for as real and as real some major
character in to tell just how like Delta
rune is an anagram for undertale the
name anagram right is that yeah yeah
that's what people are saying - yeah
flip around the words like I just want
to make sure we're all say really looks
like totally on me now looks like an owl
- yeah yeah kind of like right from the
front like God it's a dummy training
dummy yeah I was like that's the same
character
I know oh yeah what's your Facebook
account
mah Jima can i friend requests you know
oh cool yummy a crow yeah that might be
crow oh this is cool I can send me the
Hat we finally have some you have a
party undertale is all based on one
character and there's some spells some
stats as the the soul RPG system has
been fleshed out a lot more not just in
the combat system button like the
character development but for me go
passages because that's just how I do it
[Music]
lover dog the wrong character for
Halloween well
Maju was never killed a person okay
that's fair that's fair so it's
canonically yeah okay I might stab them
in the gut but I've never killed a
person I make sure I don't hit vital
organs just I'll be Toby Fox State on
Twitter this release was intended for
feedback so maybe this chapter demo will
change for the final release possibly
yeah it's like as we had mentioned
earlier it's kind of like a proof of
concept potentially maybe
we're like maybe like a beta early
access early access thank you guys all
for tuning in don't appreciate the
people hanging out appreciate your
understanding of what we're doing here
yeah this is a little on the nose saying
like if you don't hurt anyone there
might be a happy ending oh [ __ ] I've
been I've been down this road with thank
you you as a hero the moment I saw you
oh yeah a pro hero go gotta go beyond
we're going plus ultra on this dam and
the scheme is giving me the chills just
like knowing that there's something
beyond under tails I think that's a lot
for me to handle it's yeah this it
starts out a little similar to let me
tell you pass the door and then you
can't go back so look at this this is
like some hyper light drifter type
artwork right now I'll be a lot more
low-flying ya color scheme but a lot
more low five in hyper light drifter
especially because like the color of
Chris here is just like the drifter yeah
yeah that's kind of the image I first
yeah thought of just because I didn't
play undertale as as mentioned and I've
only played a little bit of hyper light
but like color scheme and like just kind
of the fit was like close yeah who'd got
any music like it this kind of reminds
me
son a vendor's is he cool you know
everyone plays games at a different pace
I would say some people really soak it
in wanna find out all the systems of
mechanics so you know how we like to
play here you know so there I would say
cool that you know you're super fast at
playing games but as many jokes as I was
making about speedrunning earlier we
definitely don't speedrun yeah oh my god
the animations and this pause is so good
you lectured them on kindness heat okay
you became tired all right
okay sometimes falsely sweet right can i
spare that but I know from magic past
apply once they're tired like he's
passed by two random guys said about two
hours for them
they're all set is hopefully high okay
clap that's awesome oh damn I didn't see
it because I only got one eye I'm like
reading the enemy oh I was real anime
like you know so I got zero experience
so hopefully I'm continuing past past a
circus run listen to this music though
someone says use your phone there's an
easter egg do it now alright alright
we're doing it now wait how about you
yeah I'm using my cell phone cell phone
okay you try to call it
well I can't talk listen to Toby he said
don't stream well first of all that's a
bad sentence
second of all like I said no well we try
to put as many upfront warnings as
possible you know like people that click
into it should know what they're getting
into and if you don't I don't know what
to say
yeah I've said this before and again is
that I won't be talking about the game
will be showing what the game is about
or anything on unsolicited platforms
which is why I requested that this
stream not be auto played on any of our
platforms so if you are seeing this it's
because you chose to be here yep and
that's that's that this is kind of a
remix - yeah this is okay never mind I'm
just going I'm getting really into it
yeah that's fine we love undertale
continue enjoy this this [ __ ] guy
over here
such were the bad person
[Music]
big in the music though 100% yeah the
the like undertale soundtrack is
probably one of the like best of all
time up there with like persona 4
episode 5 and undertale my three
favorite soundtracks of all time
okay so that's where every time someone
tells me to go like to a certain
direction because that's where to
continue I go the opposite direction
also the way I look at it too is like
and this might not be true but there's
been a few people at least like asking
where to get this game so like I feel
like generous attracts we're still
drumming up interest and it's like a
service to tell people like hey this
game is out to play yeah I can
immediately tell you if you come in
guess what there's gonna be spoilers
okay like if you read one line there
maybe it spoils something for you I
don't know but hey if it helps
potentially drum up interest for people
that might not have known or seen it
Delta ruin calm go play the game
yourself if you don't want to be here
get out dark I don't know how many times
I can say that yeah you just have like a
bot that disclaims the whole time like a
lower thirds thing yeah lower third I
can make I can literally make a lower
third above my head like or below me
that says like if you're worried about
spoilers please leave how much I mean we
could stop if that if you're worried
about like anything else if people are
worried about it I'm totally fine if you
want I'll go a couple more minutes
that's fine yeah totally fine as long as
we hit an hour that's good for a
logistical standpoint sure of two of
them they can both go sleep okay yeah
what do we do last time we lectured them
you told long little finger wag you like
you know Oh what yeah Delta run comm for
those I want to play it do make sure
that you check oh what the [ __ ]
why'd you attack oh [ __ ] whoops I guess
I accidentally press attack for all say
yeah do be careful about the deletion
stuff there's a tweet and also I'm sure
we have it somewhere so apparently the
uninstall for Delta rune just deletes
the entire directory for the uninstaller
or the directory the uninstaller is in
depend on where you installed it this
could have some consequences I recommend
you don't use the uninstaller
so just be careful don't use the onion
Staller as I said just don't use it
that's like word on the street that's
how we Foxx said it's like don't just
don't use this don't use it on Islam
also make a third formaggi Matt right I
need to do that I need to get on that
yeah I encounter new enemy types
I can screenshot them and draw them I'm
happy this combats just all yeah I love
this game already
yeah yeah this is a lot for me all right
we got two minutes to hit an hour
exactly actually we started late but
it's fine whatever it doesn't have to be
an hour I'll go for a couple moments me
I'll get into the skin two fights okay
should I take a piece I feel like so I'm
constantly running into objects and
they're asking me if I want to like
pluck a thing off the tree if I want to
take like a piece of something that's on
the table I feel like I was gonna have
consequences because they've didn't
murder too sure I'll take a piece of a
cake see what that does
I took it's a key to that broken cake
seize power master Smith to fix it okay
fix my cake maybe it's this guy
okay
[Music]
okay
[Music]
okay let's help Susan
so yeah in an undertale there was random
encounters so in here there's like it's
like Chrono Trigger or in a sense where
you see the enemy on screen and they'll
they'll come after you if they see you
so I like that a lot more because random
encounters are a little pineapple says
his music just as good it's good it's
getting there and that's a very high bar
like for me like the undertale
soundtrack is like a very high bar so
and this is showing signs of being there
okay I could have we're all say get into
get into the actions also to the passive
his actions this game is so cute
it spares someone I care about them
and I'll spare the other one [ __ ] it man
this car I like how toby fox has changed
the combat system this is dope
I want to call it well how about we get
to the next day all right yeah that's
good yeah I'm respecting whatever you
want to do man okay you have a better
gauge than I do once he gets an X a
point then we'll puzzle okay yeah what
is this a timer okay
wait let me read that again sorry check
the clock in order to solve this puzzle
you'll have to hurry okay what
oh I just needed to get all three okay
sure whatever the okay there's the next
eight points Oh down there but up here
yeah how did you know it's like you knew
yeah something something in your body
and your bones told you it's kind of no
I wait oh let's see what we can get to
another I'm really having a great time
here guy I'm trying to help him out you
know he's like maybe we can get to like
one more fight it's a candy tree over
there or something we missed a hearing
like this ago music well I can put us on
full camera without using all right we
have to stick around for a little bit
longer
how are we doing okay cuz I'm up against
some dialog I guess all right uh-oh okay
here we go got something all right this
will be our last fight yeah yeah sure
alright three Happy's locked away all
right let's be kind it's the X flattered
at work last time on these enemies all
looking on they're all flattered look at
them oh they're blushing Oh what is
that's not got a deal with their attack
Oh oh right yeah it sounds like an awful
meal for me three three glasses of milk
oh geez
we're sparing everyone no gotta do one
more turn spare this last one oh you got
22 that fixated on how can I that
sweetheart how dare you attack me while
I'm sparing you
oh is that like a heart gun is it he did
like he did like a point with like
hearts over a shirt yeah
this is the this Lancer character is
really like channeling the spirit of
sands like grace or papyrus yes because
it's kind of like dumb yeah it's kind of
a piracy type all right all right let me
go back to the save point and I'll say
from there because I want to keep my
file but these tunes well you're gonna
have to find a way to put the save on
your thing is on this PC right now so
we'll leave the music up but thank you
all for tuning in I appreciate I
appreciate the people that are you know
I wouldn't say just level-headed but you
know yeah I feel like I'm glad the
people that wanted to stay and hang out
could enjoy it I'm sure you did
everything you could to try to like you
know make sure that we do our best to
try to respect the wishes but I mean
like yeah granted you can argue that
we're still doing technically what we're
not supposed to do I guess in a way yeah
I I guess I'll say is that I try my best
to respect Tobey Fox's request for like
the 24-hour window by you know I before
the stream went up I asked my co-workers
like hey can we not do autoplay on this
and like let's not talk about the game
itself like on Twitter or something so
people won't run into it like
unsolicited discussion about the game so
I did everything I could to like make
sure that we're gonna stream this
everyone who's gonna join us are like
deliberately going in because they want
to see this so but yeah with that I want
to like thank everyone for some by happy
Halloween and you know I got some bad
news to beat up out there bro maybe not
today today's like the purge for you
today well Dan are you I'll knock them
down to one health and then I'll spare
them that's how Maggio works but uh yeah
this is Delta rune I'm still not sure
where it fits in like the undertale
scheme but we have seen undertale
characters in it I'm really excited to
dig deep into this because undertale
means a lot to me and I'm sure it means
a lot to a lot of people out there yeah
so yeah that's that awesome I have a
happy Halloween you know thanks again
for tuning in we'll be back tomorrow
either with fallout PC again cuz it's
still up I think maybe or we might do
Xbox games with cold for November which
is out tomorrow things battlefield
and hey alright since I'm in a saw since
I'm in my yeah cos a cos place when ps+
games come around
yes November I'm streaming yahooza
kiwami that's fine Bank and us Yosh Yosh
anyways thank you guys all for tuning in
peace out have a good time I got 200
gozaimasu